MATTER.
THAT'S TERRIFYING.
JEANINE PIRRO IS THE HOST OF
JUSTICE WITH JUDGE JEANINE, HER
BOOK IS OUT TODAY.
JUDGE JEANINE JOINS US TONIGHT.
IT SEEMS SIGNIFICANT TO ME
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF ALL WE'VE
SEEN OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS
THAT THE SO-CALLED
WHISTLE-BLOWER, THE PERSON WHO
COMPLAINED ABOUT THIS
CONVERSATION WAS A CAREER CIA
OFFICER.
>> AS YOU RECALL, CHUCK SCHUMER
SAID A LONG TIME AGO, YOU DON'T
MESS WITH THE INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES BECAUSE THEY'LL GET
BACK AT YOU SIX WAYS TO SUNDAY.
I MUST TELL YOU, EVERYTHING YOU
SAID IS SO ON POINT BUT THE MOST
DISAPPOINTING PART OF THIS IS
WHEN YOU'VE GOT SOMEONE JOKING
ABOUT IMPEACHING A PRESIDENT,
MAKING A PARODY ABOUT AN
ORGANIZED CRIME FAMILY AND THEN
READING WORDS THAT HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH THE ACTUAL
TRANSCRIPT, IT'S AN INDICATION
THEY DON'T HAVE A CASE WHICH IS
WHY THEY ACTUALLY HAVE TO PARODY
COME OUT LISTEN TO ME ANOTHER
SEVEN TIMES THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO GET THIS, THAT COME OF THE
OTHER THING.
IF THERE WERE AN IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE OR EVIDENCE OF ANY KIND
OF CRIMINALITY OR ANY KIND OF
ILLEGALITY, HE WOULD HAVE READ
THAT STATEMENT AND THAT WOULD'VE
BEEN THE END OF IT.
WE ARE DEALING WITH ADAM SCHIFF
AND HE IS THE SAME GUY WHO
STUMBLED OVER HIMSELF 86 TIMES
TO GET TO A CAMERA TO TELL US HE
KNEW MORE ABOUT RUSSIA COLLUSION
THEN BOB MUELLER DID AND
OBVIOUSLY HE DIDN'T.
THE SAD PART ABOUT THIS IS THIS
COUNTRY HAS AN ECONOMY THAT IS
SOARING.
WE ARE NOW IN A POSITION WITH
THE STRONGEST MILITARY EVER.
THESE HATERS WHO COULDN'T DRAG
HILLARY CLINTON ACROSS THE
PRESIDENTIAL FINISH LINE WANT TO
DO EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
IMPEACH HIM.
WE HATE HIM, WE ARE GOING TO GET
HIM OUT.
THAT'S A SAD POINT AND LET ME
MAKE ONE MORE POINTS.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS AN ABSOLUTE
RIGHT TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
WHAT HAPPENED WITH MEDDLING IN
THE 2016 ELECTION, AND NOBODY IN
CONGRESS AND ESPECIALLY THE
DEMOCRATS WHO WERE INVOLVED LIKE
JAMES COMEY, BRENNAN, THE WHOLE
LOT OF THEM IN THE INTEL
COMMUNITY HAVE THE RIGHT TO STOP
HIM AND ACCUSE HIM OF AN
IMPEACHABLE DEFENSE BECAUSE HE
NOW HAS A RIGHT TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT.
>> Tucker: THE NEXT TIME A
DEMOCRAT IS ELECTED PRESIDENT,
YOU THINK THEY WILL BE
COMFORTABLE WITH A STANDARD THEY
HAVE SET?
OF SOME UNELECTED INTEL AGENCY
GUY DOESN'T LIKE THEIR FOREIGN
POLICY, HE CAN DESTROY THEIR
ADMINISTRATION?
>> THEY AREN'T THINKING THAT FAR
IN ADVANCE BECAUSE THEY ARE SO
BLINDED BY THE HATRED, THEIR
HATRED OF DONALD TRUMP THEY
CAN'T EVEN SEE WHAT REAL
CRIMINALITY IS.
YOU DON'T GET A BILLION DOLLARS
UNLESS YOU TAKE THE PROSECUTOR
OFF THAT COMPANY THAT MY SON IS
ON THE BOARD OF BECAUSE HE'S
ABOUT READY TO INTERROGATE MY
SON AND I DON'T WANT IT TO
HAPPEN -- GIVE ME A BREAK.
>> AND I DON'T THINK YOU'VE BEEN
WATCHING CABLE NEWS, I'VE
LEARNED THIS WEEK THAT HUNTER
BIDEN WAS AN EXPERT AND
UKRAINIAN ENERGY POLICY AND
DESERVE THOSE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
>> DO YOU WANT TO KNOW WHY HE'S
NOT IN THE MILITARY?
>> Tucker: I DON'T WANT TO
HEAR IT.
I KNOW HIM, HE'S A NICE GUY BUT
IT'S FAIR TO ASK THESE
QUESTIONS.
>> HOW TO GET A BILLION DOLLARS